I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello everyone.
Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的“办公室剧迷”播客。每周，我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室女郎 6.0 版。大家好。嗨。
Angela.
Did you get my audio memo about my knees yet?
No.
Did you leave it on the office?
the drive-in. Yeah. I was talking to my mom. That's fine. I always talked to her on my drive-in.
I'm so excited about my knees. I have to share. K-N-E, your knees. My knees. Okay, what's happening?
Okay, you know, my knees have been aching from my tamoxifen for like so long that it became just like
this baseline existence. Okay. I didn't complain about it much. You're like, oh, I've heard you complain
安吉拉。你收到我关于膝盖的语音备忘录了吗？没有。你把它留在办公室了吗？在车里。对。我当时在跟我妈说话。没关系。我开车时总是跟她说话。我为我的膝盖感到兴奋。我不得不分享。K-N-E，你的膝盖。我的膝盖。好的，怎么了？好吧，你知道的，我的膝盖因为吃他莫昔芬已经痛了很久，以至于它变成了我的一种基准生活状态。好吧。我没怎么抱怨。你会觉得，哦，我听你抱怨过
about a lot of things, but I've been keeping the knees to myself. Knees weren't on the list.
No.
But I went to acupuncture yesterday for my hot flashes which are back, which you've gotten
many messages about.
And while I was there, I just offhandedly said, by the way, my knees are like also super achy.
Lady, I left that acupuncture session, 35 minutes of acupuncture.
My knees are not aching.
It was one of those things.
很多事情，但我一直把膝盖的事藏在心里。膝盖不在清单上。没有。但我昨天去针灸治疗我的潮热，我的潮热又犯了，你已经收到了很多关于这个的消息。当我在那儿的时候，我顺便说了一句，顺便说一下，我的膝盖也超级酸痛。天哪，我结束了那次针灸疗程，35分钟的针灸。我的膝盖不痛了。那是那种感觉之一。
You know like when you're sick and then you get better and you're like, oh my God, I was
so sick.
I didn't even realize that cold was so bad.
that's how my knees were.
Like now that I'm like, I forgot knees could be forgettable.
Like I'm just walking around, not thinking about how bad my knees hurt.
We parked at the same time and we got right into just like catching up, you know, chatter.
I thought you had a pep in your step.
你知道就像你生病了然后病好了，你会想，哦天哪，我病得好厉害。我甚至没有意识到那个感冒那么严重。这就是我膝盖的情况。就像现在我——我忘了膝盖是可以被遗忘的。就像我只是在四处走动，根本不用去想我的膝盖有多痛。我们同时停车，然后马上就开始叙旧，你知道的，闲聊。我以为你走路很有精神。
I was so excited.
I just thought you were in a really good mood.
But maybe it's also because you don't have like, out, you know, when you walk.
Yeah.
So all my tamoxifen ladies, I just want to throw it out there.
If you're having the achy joints, which is a very common side effect, I don't know.
The acupuncture, it was great.
Okay.
我太兴奋了。我只是觉得你心情真的很好。但也许这也是因为你走路时没有，你知道的，那种痛苦。是的。所以所有吃他莫昔芬的女士们，我只是想提一下。如果你有关节酸痛，这是一个非常常见的副作用，我不知道。针灸，真的很棒。好吧。
Not working on the hot flashes right now.
But that's all right.
We're one thing at a time.
Okay.
One thing at a time.
All right.
Should we get into this episode?
Because we had a very hilarious start to our day so far involving you, Angela.
现在对潮热不管用。但没关系。我们一次只解决一件事。好吧。一次只解决一件事。好吧。我们开始聊这一集吧？因为到目前为止，我们今天有个非常搞笑的开端，跟你有磁，安吉拉。
Yeah.
Well, in honor of today's episode, you guys, I am dressed in Dwight's.
mustard shirt, and I brought a brown tie, but I didn't know how to tie it.
Josh was already gone when I was getting dressed, and so Sam tried, then Jenna tried.
First I gave up. I immediately gave up. I couldn't remember. I panicked. My mind went completely
blank. I'd never put a tie on before. And then it took two minutes for all my life to come back
to me. Yeah. Oh my goodness. I tried. Eventually Sam got it. It's not great, though, Sam.
No, no, it's not ideal. To be fair, like the back part is longer than the
是的。嗯，为了致敬今天的这一集，伙计们，我穿着德怀特的芥末黄衬衫，我还带了一条棕色领带，但我不知道怎么打。我穿衣服时乔什已经走了，所以萨姆试了一下，然后珍娜试了一下。首先我放弃了。我立刻放弃了。我想不起来了。我惊慌失措。我的脑子一片空白。我以前从来没系过领带。然后我花了两分钟才让我的生活记忆全部恢复。 yeah. Oh my goodness. I tried. Eventually Sam got it. It's not great, though, Sam. No, no, not ideal. To be fair, like the back part is longer than the
front part, but it's on. You know what? It's a win. And do I look like Dwight? No, I mean, you look
kind of adorable. Yes, you do. Thank you. Well, why don't we tell everyone what we're doing today?
Yes. This is a perfect example of what I love about our new format for Office Lady 6.0.
Yeah, it was inspired, you guys, by a letter sent in from Christy D. in Wheeling, West Virginia.
she titled her letter, Diaries of the Mustard Shirt.
You were so excited when you got this piece of mail.
You told me we are doing an episode about Dwight's mustard shirt.
And you have not told me what Christy sent in.
front part, but it's on. You know what? It's a win. And do I look like Dwight? No, I mean, you look kind of adorable. Yes, you do. Thank you. Well, why don't we tell everyone what we're doing today? Yes. This is a perfect example of what I love about our new format for Office Lady 6.0. Yeah, it was inspired, you guys, by a letter sent in from Christy D. in Wheeling, West Virginia. she titled her letter, Diaries of the Mustard Shirt. You were so excited when you got this piece of mail. You told me we are doing an episode about Dwight's mustard shirt. And you have not told me what Christy sent in.
You got this letter, snail mail, and you have hidden it from me.
Mm-hmm.
And also, Jenna, then this led you to have the idea to deep dive Pam's cardigans.
Yes.
So today's episode is Dwight's Mustard Shirt and Pam's Cardigans.
and we both have some fun nuggets to share.
We have not told each other.
You got this letter, snail mail, and you have hidden it from me. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. And also, Jenna, then this led you to have the idea to deep dive Pam's cardigans. Yes. So today's episode is Dwight's Mustard Shirt and Pam's Cardigans. and we both have some fun nuggets to share. We have not told each other.
I have something that I am so excited for you to hear.
It is from someone you know very well,
and you do not know this information about Dwight's shirt.
Wow.
I know.
Okay, well, first, let's start with our chit-chat suggestions sent in by Melissa C.
From Washington.
Hey, ladies.
I have something that I am so excited for you to hear. It is from someone you know very well, and you do not know this information about Dwight's shirt. Wow. I know. Okay, well, first, let's start with our chit-chat suggestions sent in by Melissa C. From Washington. Hey, ladies.
So my chit-chat suggestion is the opposite of
pet peeves. Plenty of people have pet peeves, little things that drive them crazy. But I'm
wondering if you guys have anything that I like to call dainty delights. Just little random things in
life that bring you a disproportionate amount of joy. A couple of those things for me are if I'm
able to do the perfect eyeliner swoop in one stroke, I could squeal for joy. Or if I have just the
right amount of an ingredient when I'm cooking something, it just brings me so much satisfaction.
So I would just love to hear what your dainty delights are. Thanks, ladies. I just love the expression dainty delights. Same. And you know, Melissa, I thought a lot about this when we chose this chit chat for this week because I realized something about myself that I hadn't really put together before. What is it? That dainty delights are what get me through life. It's not really the big milestone moments, you know, that sometimes everyone.
and that's what they clamber on about.
So my chit-chat suggestion is the opposite of pet peeves. Plenty of people have pet peeves, little things that drive them crazy. But I'm wondering if you guys have anything that I like to call dainty delights. Just little random things in life that bring you a disproportionate amount of joy. A couple of those things for me are if I'm able to do the perfect eyeliner swoop in one stroke, I could squeal for joy. Or if I have just the right amount of an ingredient when I'm cooking something, it just brings me so much satisfaction. So I would just love to hear what your dainty delights are. Thanks, ladies. I just love the expression dainty delights. Same. And you know, Melissa, I thought a lot about this when we chose this chit chat for this week because I realized something about myself that I hadn't really put together before. What is it? That dainty delights are what get me through life. It's not really the big milestone moments, you know, that sometimes everyone. and that's what they clamber on about.
But the dainty delights, like, just get me through whatever life throws my way.
It's true.
And I love this moment to name them and to think about them because I thought of so many little things.
Same.
All right.
What did you think of?
I mean, just so many little things.
Like, you know, I just love my back porch.
But the dainty delights, like, just get me through whatever life throws my way. It's true. And I love this moment to name them and to think about them because I thought of so many little things. Same. All right. What did you think of? I mean, just so many little things. Like, you know, I just love my back porch.
You know, for years, I didn't really have a table.
it was dirt and not enough concrete and we finally just made a space where I could put a table,
you know? And I love it. And I stood out there a couple times a week in the morning, which is my
cup of tea. And I just sit there and I listen to the birds and I look at my feeders and I'm just so
happy. I know this about you. Yeah. It's your most favorite place to be. It is. Yeah.
And then one of the things I love to do, and I actually have one for you, lady. I made it for you. I did not
bring it in today because I just want to bring it straight to your house. Okay. You know, I love to
repopulate succulents. So I have my big mama succulent, I call her. She's super old. She's really big.
You know, for years, I didn't really have a table. it was dirt and not enough concrete and we finally just made a space where I could put a table, you know? And I love it. And I stood out there a couple times a week in the morning, which is my cup of tea. And I just sit there and I listen to the birds and I look at my feeders and I'm just so happy. I know this about you. Yeah. It's your most favorite place to be. It is. Yeah. And then one of the things I love to do, and I actually have one for you, lady. I made it for you. I did not bring it in today because I just want to bring it straight to your house. Okay. You know, I love to repopulate succulents. So I have my big mama succulent, I call her. She's super old. She's really big.
And whenever she's too full and starts leaning over her pot, I take a little piece and I put it in a
pot. So now I have her children all around my house. And then also I'll just put it, you know,
in the ground if one falls off. And so I just have succulents everywhere. So I took some,
clippings from one of my big pots and I put it into a pot for you.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Yeah.
But I love doing that.
I've done that for people before and I've done it for neighbors or just like a teacher.
And whenever she's too full and starts leaning over her pot, I take a little piece and I put it in a pot. So now I have her children all around my house. And then also I'll just put it, you know, in the ground if one falls off. And so I just have succulents everywhere. So I took some, clippings from one of my big pots and I put it into a pot for you. Oh, I'm so excited. Yeah. But I love doing that. I've done that for people before and I've done it for neighbors or just like a teacher.
And it makes me so happy to see my succulent.
It's like I feel so connected to nature in a way and like sharing nature like that.
Yeah.
Those are two that came to the top of my mind.
Well, I know I've shared this on the podcast before that I love my first.
cup of coffee in the morning. You do. And I think I've also shared that my favorite way to have my first
cup of coffee is in a handmade mug. Right. Something made by hand by a person. I just love
touching a piece of art while I'm drinking that first cup of coffee. So I collect those. And in general,
And it makes me so happy to see my succulent. It's like I feel so connected to nature in a way and like sharing nature like that. Yeah. Those are two that came to the top of my mind. Well, I know I've shared this on the podcast before that I love my first. cup of coffee in the morning. You do. And I think I've also shared that my favorite way to have my first cup of coffee is in a handmade mug. Right. Something made by hand by a person. I just love touching a piece of art while I'm drinking that first cup of coffee. So I collect those. And in general,
I just like to drink coffee out of a mug. If I have to go somewhere in the morning,
I don't love a travel mug. Lady, I've never shared this with you. You know,
you. So I have a lot of tennis rituals, you don't know. Okay. So I take my tea in a travel mug,
a big one, to tennis in the morning, but I pack in my tennis bag a ceramic coffee mug that I
then pour it into when I get to tennis because I don't like the metal. Like, I don't know. I like
the mug taste. Do you know what I mean? Well, that's what I do when we come to podcast. I bring it in
the insulated thing, but then I have my pockets mug that I pour it into when I get here. But
But when I do school drop-off, I still want coffee.
I just like to drink coffee out of a mug. If I have to go somewhere in the morning, I don't love a travel mug. Lady, I've never shared this with you. You know, you. So I have a lot of tennis rituals, you don't know. Okay. So I take my tea in a travel mug, a big one, to tennis in the morning, but I pack in my tennis bag a ceramic coffee mug that I then pour it into when I get to tennis because I don't like the metal. Like, I don't know. I like the mug taste. Do you know what I mean? Well, that's what I do when we come to podcast. I bring it in the insulated thing, but then I have my pockets mug that I pour it into when I get here. But But when I do school drop-off, I still want coffee.
And I'm just going to do the school route and then drive home.
I've got like an hour loop to do all the drop-offs and all the things.
And I want coffee with me, but I don't want to drink it out of it to go mug.
So my day-do delight is that I found a ceramic travel mug.
It is basically a mug without a handle that fits in your cup holder.
And it comes with like a washable lid.
But you're drinking out of ceramic?
Yes, while I'm driving.
And I'm just going to do the school route and then drive home. I've got like an hour loop to do all the drop-offs and all the things. And I want coffee with me, but I don't want to drink it out of it to go mug. So my day-do delight is that I found a ceramic travel mug. It is basically a mug without a handle that fits in your cup holder. And it comes with like a washable lid. But you're drinking out of ceramic? Yes, while I'm driving.
And I don't even put the lid on because I'm just...
You're crazy like that.
I am.
But it's funny because in the carpool line,
there's always this one other mom that I see
and she's got like a full regular mug of coffee with her.
And we've talked about it.
I've been like, I see you.
And I don't even put the lid on because I'm just... You're crazy like that. I am. But it's funny because in the carpool line, there's always this one other mom that I see and she's got like a full regular mug of coffee with her. And we've talked about it. I've been like, I see you.
I know this because I've done that.
I've driven with a mug of coffee.
I've gone for walks in my neighborhood holding a mug of coffee in the morning.
I once sent you a picture.
I was on vacation and I took a mug of tea on my walk and I sent it to you not knowing this
about you until right this moment.
And Jenna, I remember what you wrote back.
You were like, oh, this is my favorite thing.
I know this because I've done that. I've driven with a mug of coffee. I've gone for walks in my neighborhood holding a mug of coffee in the morning. I once sent you a picture. I was on vacation and I took a mug of tea on my walk and I sent it to you not knowing this about you until right this moment. And Jenna, I remember what you wrote back. You were like, oh, this is my favorite thing.
And I this whole time thought it was because I was on a beach.
No.
It's because I had a mug in my hand.
on the beach with a mug of your drink. You remember the one I said you from Hawaii? Yes, I do.
And I was like, oh, she loves Hawaii. Not that you don't, but it was the mug that spoke to you.
Yes. So when I found this item, it was at like a little breakfast place. And I saw it and I like exclaimed.
I was like, look at this. I've been looking for it because it is really hard to drive with a mug of coffee.
Well, it's probably not safe.
And I this whole time thought it was because I was on a beach. No. It's because I had a mug in my hand. on the beach with a mug of your drink. You remember the one I said you from Hawaii? Yes, I do. And I was like, oh, she loves Hawaii. Not that you don't, but it was the mug that spoke to you. Yes. So when I found this item, it was at like a little breakfast place. And I saw it and I like exclaimed. I was like, look at this. I've been looking for it because it is really hard to drive with a mug of coffee. Well, it's probably not safe.
It's not a good idea.
But I immediately texted the other coffee mug mom, and I was like, I'm going to make your day right now.
Look at what I found.
So that is my dainty to light.
I really love it every morning.
And I have found a way that no matter where I'm going or what I'm doing, I can have my coffee out of a ceramic mug, my travel one.
It's not handmade.
But it serves a purpose.
It's not a good idea. But I immediately texted the other coffee mug mom, and I was like, I'm going to make your day right now. Look at what I found. So that is my dainty to light. I really love it every morning. And I have found a way that no matter where I'm going or what I'm doing, I can have my coffee out of a ceramic mug, my travel one. It's not handmade. But it serves a purpose.
Yeah.
But I bet I could find a handmade.
version of it.
You know, it just has to fit in a cup holder, basically.
I think this might be a case for a mom detective.
Mm-hmm.
Or a lady who Googles.
Sort of one in the same.
Yeah. But I bet I could find a handmade. version of it. You know, it just has to fit in a cup holder, basically. I think this might be a case for a mom detective. Mm-hmm. Or a lady who Googles. Sort of one in the same.
Sam, do you have a dainty delight?
I do.
I think this counts.
The last two or three times that I've come home from the studio recording here,
the music I've been listening to, the song has faded out exactly as I'm parking my car.
Like when I turn my key off, it's like the last symbol or the last
guitar is just ringing out and I turn my key off. And it's, it's as close to what I imagine doing
heroin must be like, just this warm, gooey feeling that spreads over me for at least an hour.
Sam, do you have a dainty delight? I do. I think this counts. The last two or three times that I've come home from the studio recording here, the music I've been listening to, the song has faded out exactly as I'm parking my car. Like when I turn my key off, it's like the last symbol or the last guitar is just ringing out and I turn my key off. And it's, it's as close to what I imagine doing heroin must be like, just this warm, gooey feeling that spreads over me for at least an hour.
That is such like a feeling of satisfaction though when anything times out that way.
That and I recommend the subreddit R slash things fitting perfectly. It's just a collection of
like somebody buying a DVD and it perfectly fitting into the missing slot that they
on their shelf or like a puzzle piece being put in.
The last puzzle piece is a popular one.
It's all like this feeling, this dainty delight, that gooey feeling you get.
I love it.
That is such like a feeling of satisfaction though when anything times out that way. That and I recommend the subreddit R slash things fitting perfectly. It's just a collection of like somebody buying a DVD and it perfectly fitting into the missing slot that they on their shelf or like a puzzle piece being put in. The last puzzle piece is a popular one. It's all like this feeling, this dainty delight, that gooey feeling you get. I love it. I love it.
Matt, Matt, what about you?
Sam, I love when the song ends right as you're pulling it.
There's nothing like that.
It is, yeah.
Is this particularly like a man thing?
I think it might be a straight white guy thing.
I think it might be you're imagining you're walking off stage having just performed.
You're in your own.
Matt, Matt, what about you? Sam, I love when the song ends right as you're pulling it. There's nothing like that. It is, yeah. Is this particularly like a man thing? I think it might be a straight white guy thing. I think it might be you're imagining you're walking off stage having just performed. You're in your own.
music video? I forgot about that. I love that. I do love my mugs. I found a dainty delight in a very
unexpected place, which is physical therapy that I've been going to recently. I had a minor
knee injury, and I was really not looking forward to going to physical therapy. And it is the best
vibes in there. It's this like husband and wife shop, and there's all these people in there.
And we're talking about their hip replacements and shoulder replacements, and you get like this
special treatment, like ice packs and the electric zapper thing on your knee. And it,
It's really become the highlight of my week.
I have friends in there.
music video? I forgot about that. I love that. I do love my mugs. I found a dainty delight in a very unexpected place, which is physical therapy that I've been going to recently. I had a minor knee injury, and I was really not looking forward to going to physical therapy. And it is the best vibes in there. It's this like husband and wife shop, and there's all these people in there. And we're talking about their hip replacements and shoulder replacements, and you get like this special treatment, like ice packs and the electric zapper thing on your knee. And it, It's really become the highlight of my week. I have friends in there.
We chat about our injuries.
We chat about music and sports.
It's just you never know where you're going to find community.
I love it.
That really makes me happy.
I think that's what you're going tomorrow.
I can't wait.
You can't wait.
We chat about our injuries. We chat about music and sports. It's just you never know where you're going to find community. I love it. That really makes me happy. I think that's what you're going tomorrow. I can't wait. You can't wait.
That's the highlight of your week.
Oh my gosh.
Well, Melissa, thank you so much.
Yeah, we really enjoyed that chit-chat.
And we're going to take a break.
And when we come back, it's time for diaries.
Of the mustard shirt.
The Second World War is the largest event in human history.
That's the highlight of your week. Oh my gosh. Well, Melissa, thank you so much. Yeah, we really enjoyed that chit-chat. And we're going to take a break. And when we come back, it's time for diaries. Of the mustard shirt. The Second World War is the largest event in human history.
A 20-part series with Tom Hanks.
No part of the globe was untouched. No life unchanged.
Experience the ultimate account of World War II.
Every single person had a story.
These are the stories that make us who we are.
Listen to World War II with Tom Hanks on Apple, Sponoff.
or wherever you get your podcasts.
Right.
A 20-part series with Tom Hanks. No part of the globe was untouched. No life unchanged. Experience the ultimate account of World War II. Every single person had a story. These are the stories that make us who we are. Listen to World War II with Tom Hanks on Apple, Sponoff. or wherever you get your podcasts. Right.
We're back and Angel and Sam have been, I don't know, in secret discussions about some
secret clip.
I sent a secret clip this morning.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Well, my share today, as you guys know, is all about Dwight's mustard shirt.
And if you remember when we had our amazing costume designer on the podcast, Carrie Bennett,
We're back and Angel and Sam have been, I don't know, in secret discussions about some secret clip. I sent a secret clip this morning. Okay. Mm-hmm. Okay. Well, my share today, as you guys know, is all about Dwight's mustard shirt. And if you remember when we had our amazing costume designer on the podcast, Carrie Bennett,
she talked about how when she was putting together the costumes for the office,
she went to an actual paper company called the Glendale Paper Company to observe the look and the feel of this small business.
And many of those looks inspired the look of the Dundermifflin employees, including the very famous Dwight Wolf t-shirt.
But I wanted to start this section with a very special message from a dear friend who had an inside scoop on the origin of the very first Dwight short sleeves.
button-down shirt. Okay, here it is. Hey, everybody. Hey, office ladies. It's me, Holiday,
wife of Rain Wilson for 300 years, you know, a little over 30 years, but it's so good to be here.
And listen, I know that there's been some talk and magic and mystery about the origin of Dwight's
mustard shirt. So I just wanted to add a little story to the trivia podcast.
she talked about how when she was putting together the costumes for the office, she went to an actual paper company called the Glendale Paper Company to observe the look and the feel of this small business. And many of those looks inspired the look of the Dundermifflin employees, including the very famous Dwight Wolf t-shirt. But I wanted to start this section with a very special message from a dear friend who had an inside scoop on the origin of the very first Dwight short sleeves. button-down shirt. Okay, here it is. Hey, everybody. Hey, office ladies. It's me, Holiday, wife of Rain Wilson for 300 years, you know, a little over 30 years, but it's so good to be here. And listen, I know that there's been some talk and magic and mystery about the origin of Dwight's mustard shirt. So I just wanted to add a little story to the trivia podcast.
on this one, you know, as I said, Rain and I have been together a long time. And whenever he'd get an
audition, we would kind of make up a costume, you know. There weren't that many auditions back in
those days, and we were really, really broke. So we would always go and get stuff for the audition.
So in this case, for the office, they went in for the first audition and he read for a bunch of
roles, but then didn't get a callback for like six months. So by the time he heard about this
call back. I was really, really pregnant and we were even more broke. So we were like, oh my God,
we got to find this outfit for this character. And I was inspired by pictures of my father,
who was a dentist, and he was like the president of his dental school class. And he wore these
on this one, you know, as I said, Rain and I have been together a long time. And whenever he'd get an audition, we would kind of make up a costume, you know. There weren't that many auditions back in those days, and we were really, really broke. So we would always go and get stuff for the audition. So in this case, for the office, they went in for the first audition and he read for a bunch of roles, but then didn't get a callback for like six months. So by the time he heard about this call back. I was really, really pregnant and we were even more broke. So we were like, oh my god, we got to find this outfit for this character. And I was inspired by pictures of my father, who was a dentist, and he was like the president of his dental school class. And he wore these
really shirts, just like that, short-sleeved pen protector, you know. And we were like,
where can we go for that? So we went to Sears at the Oaks. I don't even know.
seers exists anymore, but anyway, we were looking for like flammable, something that would like
catch fire. It's that really fake material, had to be the color of what might be the inside of a diaper.
So, and we found the mustard shirt and this green one and then went home and did a bunch of stuff
with the hair and that part came out of it. So then it went really well as, as we,
we can see. And they tried lots of different costumes and just kept going back to that mustard
shirt. And they're like, listen, you got to go buy them out from Sears. So we went back to Oaks,
really shirts, just like that, short-sleeved pen protector, you know. And we were like, where can we go for that? So we went to Sears at the Oaks. I don't even know. seers exists anymore, but anyway, we were looking for like flammable, something that would like catch fire. It's that really fake material, had to be the color of what might be the inside of a diaper. So, and we found the mustard shirt and this green one and then went home and did a bunch of stuff with the hair and that part came out of it. So then it went really well as, as we, we can see. And they tried lots of different costumes and just kept going back to that mustard shirt. And they're like, listen, you got to go buy them out from Sears. So we went back to Oaks,
got them all. And there you have it. So I'm wondering if NBC owes me money, frankly. But listen,
love you guys. Love all you all. And just want to send a thank you, shout out to you, Angela,
and you and Steve and Nancy for coming and supporting our organization Lee Day on the tennis court.
And if you ever need any costume ideas for a new tennis dress or whatever, I will take you shopping.
Love you. Bye.
That is amazing.
And lady, while she was telling that story, I pulled up Rain's audition video.
And he is wearing, he looks like in the video he's.
got them all. And there you have it. So I'm wondering if NBC owes me money, frankly. But listen, love you guys. Love all you all. And just want to send a thank you, shout out to you, Angela, and you and Steve and Nancy for coming and supporting our organization Lee Day on the tennis court. And if you ever need any costume ideas for a new tennis dress or whatever, I will take you shopping. Love you. Bye. That is amazing. And lady, while she was telling that story, I pulled up Rain's audition video. And he is wearing, he looks like in the video he's.
wearing the kind of greenish one.
Because they bought two.
Yeah.
But the whole look, like the hair, it's amazing.
I had no idea.
Wow.
Isn't that just so fantastic?
wearing the kind of greenish one. Because they bought two. Yeah. But the whole look, like the hair, it's amazing. Yeah. I had no idea. Wow. Isn't that just so fantastic?
Just their partnership.
Yeah.
Their marriage is so special.
They are just really each other's rock.
And I just, it transported me back to those early days, you know, when you had an audition
and you're scrambling with your friend or your partner.
just like, can you help me put together this outfit?
Like, I want to look the part.
Just their partnership. Yeah. Their marriage is so special. They are just really each other's rock. And I just, it transported me back to those early days, you know, when you had an audition and you're scrambling with your friend or your partner. just like, can you help me put together this outfit? Like, I want to look the part.
It just, again, it's an example of how open like Greg was to our vision of our characters
because he borrowed so much of what we put into our auditions, costume, hair, look, all of it.
Yeah, so I've been holding on to this for so long because when I was at the Lee Day, Haiti
dinner that we had after the tennis event,
some fans had put together questions and they wanted to ask Rain about this mustard shirt,
this iconic look. And he was like, well, really, Holiday is the one that should answer that
question. And she told the story. And I was like, oh my goodness, we have to share this on the
podcast. Yeah. I mean, I never knew that they put the outfit together themselves. Amazing.
It just, again, it's an example of how open like Greg was to our vision of our characters because he borrowed so much of what we put into our auditions, costume, hair, look, all of it. Yeah, so I've been holding on to this for so long because when I was at the Lee Day, Haiti dinner that we had after the tennis event, some fans had put together questions and they wanted to ask Rain about this mustard shirt, this iconic look. And he was like, well, really, Holiday is the one that should answer that question. And she told the story. And I was like, oh my goodness, we have to share this on the podcast. Yeah. I mean, I never knew that they put the outfit together themselves. Amazing.
Amazing. And I do want to say there are some comparisons online to Dwight's look to that of two
different characters on the movie Office Space from 1999. David Herman plays Michael Bolton and
Stephen Root, who plays Milton, both kind of have this short sleeve buttoned-down shirt look.
Yeah. That probably looked a lot like Holiday's Dad. Yeah. That was sort of that outdated style.
I did a side-by-side, because I know you love a side-by-side. I love a side-by-side.
And I'll put it in our stories, but I do see it. Here it is. Oh, yeah. I see it.
Mm-hmm. There's something about the short-sleeve shirt with the tie. It's just a special kind of person.
Yeah, I get it. It's like you're hot under your suit jacket. I mean, especially as a woman with hot flashes.
Amazing. And I do want to say there are some comparisons online to Dwight's look to that of two different characters on the movie Office Space from 1999. David Herman plays Michael Bolton and Stephen Root, who plays Milton, both kind of have this short sleeve buttoned-down shirt look. Yeah. That probably looked a lot like Holiday's Dad. Yeah. That was sort of that outdated style. I did a side-by-side, because I know you love a side-by-side. I love a side-by-side. And I'll put it in our stories, but I do see it. Here it is. Oh, yeah. I see it. Mm-hmm. There's something about the short-sleeve shirt with the tie. It's just a special kind of person. Yeah, I get it. It's like you're hot under your suit jacket. I mean, especially as a woman with hot flashes.
You would do the shirt. I would do a short-sleeve shirt under my blazer.
Well, I went to the show Bible to see what it said about Dwight's shirts. And per the show Bible, this is
what it says. Dwight doesn't like long-sleeve shirts. Not enough blood circulating to his hands.
Yes, he has a line about that. And he has a shirt guy in the garment district of New York.
Wow. Wow. But now let's really dig in with this fantastic letter sent in from Christy D.
in Wheeling, West Virginia. Here's the opening paragraph titled Diaries of the Mustard Shirt.
Dear office ladies, I know Dwight is known for wearing a mustard shirt.
I decided to find out if that is truly his favorite shirt.
You would do the shirt. I would do a short-sleeve shirt under my blazer. Well, I went to the show Bible to see what it said about Dwight's shirts. And per the show Bible, this is what it says. Dwight doesn't like long-sleeve shirts. Not enough blood circulating to his hands. Yes, he has a line about that. And he has a shirt guy in the garment district of New York. Wow. Wow. But now let's really dig in with this fantastic letter sent in from Christy D. in Wheeling, West Virginia. Here's the opening paragraph titled Diaries of the Mustard Shirt. Dear office ladies, I know Dwight is known for wearing a mustard shirt. I decided to find out if that is truly his favorite shirt.
Let me first explain how I broke down the shirts.
If the opening was a different shirt than the rest of the show, it counted.
If the opening was the same day as the rest of the show, it only counted as one shirt.
If there was a flashback, it did not count.
And then in parentheses, she said, I did count the tucks worn in threat level midnight
because it was such a big part of the episode.
And at this point, I'm just making up the rules as I go.
Okay.
Let me first explain how I broke down the shirts. If the opening was a different shirt than the rest of the show, it counted. If the opening was the same day as the rest of the show, it only counted as one shirt. If there was a flashback, it did not count. And then in parentheses, she said, I did count the tucks worn in threat level midnight because it was such a big part of the episode. And at this point, I'm just making up the rules as I go. Okay.
Got it.
If Dwight wore a shirt, then changed and changed back into the original shirt, it only counted
as one shirt.
For example, season two, episode six, Dwight has on a mustard shirt, then he changes for the
fight, then he changes back into the mustard shirt when they get back to the office.
That only counts as one mustard shirt.
I mean, she really dug in, lady.
I appreciate that she has a system.
Got it. If Dwight wore a shirt, then changed and changed back into the original shirt, it only counted as one shirt. For example, season two, episode six, Dwight has on a mustard shirt, then he changes for the fight, then he changes back into the mustard shirt when they get back to the office. That only counts as one mustard shirt. I mean, she really dug in, lady. I appreciate that she has a system.
Well, lady, I went through her entire accounting.
of every single type of shirt that Dwight wore, it's 11 pages.
Wow.
Season by season.
And since my focus today is about specifically Dwight's mustard shirt,
here are some of the stats from Christy's document.
In season one, no mustard shirt the entire season.
Dwight wore these colors, shades of gray, lightish-brownish green,
Well, lady, I went through her entire accounting. of every single type of shirt that Dwight wore, it's 11 pages. Wow. Season by season. And since my focus today is about specifically Dwight's mustard shirt, here are some of the stats from Christy's document. In season one, no mustard shirt the entire season. Dwight wore these colors, shades of gray, lightish-brownish green,
and one black anime shirt.
Wow, but all short sleeve.
All short sleeve.
Oh, this is a short sleeve document here.
Okay.
Short sleeve is we assumed.
Yes.
and one black anime shirt. Wow, but all short sleeve. All short sleeve. Oh, this is a short sleeve document here. Okay. Short sleeve is we assumed. Yes. Yes.
In season two, we have our very first mustard shirt siding, episode two, sexual harassment.
In the original version, if you go to one minute and 33 seconds, Dwight's iconic mustard shirt makes its television debut.
I can't believe that we didn't get a mustard shirt until season two.
It kind of blows my mind.
Yeah, it was like shades of grays and light blues and greens.
Okay.
In season two, there were a total of seven mustard sightings.
In season three, there were a total of nine mustard shirts.
In season two, we have our very first mustard shirt siding, episode two, sexual harassment. In the original version, if you go to one minute and 33 seconds, Dwight's iconic mustard shirt makes its television debut. I can't believe that we didn't get a mustard shirt until season two. It kind of blows my mind. Yeah, it was like shades of grays and light blues and greens. Okay. In season two, there were a total of seven mustard sightings. In season three, there were a total of nine mustard shirts.
Season four has seven.
Then we have the trifecta of the big mustard shirt seasons.
Are you ready?
Yes.
Season five is our big winner, 22 mustard shirts.
What?
Wait, season five had like 26 episodes and he wore 22 mustard shirts?
Correct.
Season four has seven. Then we have the trifecta of the big mustard shirt seasons. Are you ready? Yes. Season five is our big winner, 22 mustard shirts. What? Wait, season five had like 26 episodes and he wore 22 mustard shirts? Correct.
Wow.
Then season six had 15 mustard shirts.
Shirts, Season 7 had 18, season 8, 7, season 9, 6, a total of 91 mustard shirts in the entire series.
Okay, 201 episodes of the office, 91 mustard shirts.
There you go.
Wow.
Lastly, I really thought we should hear from Dwight himself on how he regards his famous mustard shirt.
It's from Season 5, Episode 9, Frame Toby.
Wow. Then season six had 15 mustard shirts. Shirts, Season 7 had 18, season 8, 7, season 9, 6, a total of 91 mustard shirts in the entire series. Okay, 201 episodes of the office, 91 mustard shirts. There you go. Wow. Lastly, I really thought we should hear from Dwight himself on how he regards his famous mustard shirt. It's from Season 5, Episode 9, Frame Toby.
Okay, let's get this started.
Okay.
What are you doing?
I am the bait.
For what?
Men find me desirable.
No, no, no.
Oh, it's a good day, too.
Okay, let's get this started. Okay. What are you doing? I am the bait. For what? Men find me desirable. No, no, no. Oh, it's a good day, too.
I'm wearing my mustard shirt.
You're the bait for Toby?
Mm-hmm.
No.
It's a good day, too.
I'm wearing my mustard shirt.
Yeah.
I love it that we refer to it as a mustard shirt.
I'm wearing my mustard shirt. You're the bait for Toby? Mm-hmm. No. It's a good day, too. I'm wearing my mustard shirt. Yeah. I love it that we refer to it as a mustard shirt.
It's perfect.
Yeah.
And I want to wrap up my Dwight's mustard shirt section of this episode with this that I've read online.
I was really curious.
if Dwight thinks his mustard shirt is his lucky shirt, right?
It's a good day because he's wearing his mustard shirt.
Then what does liking the color yellow say about you?
Oh.
It's perfect. Yeah. And I want to wrap up my Dwight's mustard shirt section of this episode with this that I've read online. I was really curious. if Dwight thinks his mustard shirt is his lucky shirt, right? It's a good day because he's wearing his mustard shirt. Then what does liking the color yellow say about you? Oh.
So this is according to empower yourself with color psychology.
I found on the internet.
And there was a whole list of different characteristics of your personality,
but here are the ones I thought spoke to Dwight.
If your favorite color is yellow, you might have a personality.
that can be very critical of yourself as well as others.
You are a perfectionist.
You analyze everything all the time and are methodical in your thinking.
So this is according to empower yourself with color psychology. I found on the internet. And there was a whole list of different characteristics of your personality, but here are the ones I thought spoke to Dwight. If your favorite color is yellow, you might have a personality. that can be very critical of yourself as well as others. You are a perfectionist. You analyze everything all the time and are methodical in your thinking.
With a yellow personality, you're impulsive and make quick decisions,
but often out of anxiety, jump in too quickly and rush things rather than taking things at a steady pace.
Maybe Dwight, maybe not on that one.
Yeah.
Oh, it also said you have a happy disposition and are cheerful and fun to be with.
So maybe not Dwight on that one.
It also says you have a strong independent streak in you and are selective with your choice of friends,
keeping a small group of close and like-minded friends rather than being involved in team events
With a yellow personality, you're impulsive and make quick decisions, but often out of anxiety, jump in too quickly and rush things rather than taking things at a steady pace. Maybe Dwight, maybe not on that one. Yeah. Oh, it also said you have a happy disposition and are cheerful and fun to be with. So maybe not Dwight on that one. It also says you have a strong independent streak in you and are selective with your choice of friends, keeping a small group of close and like-minded friends rather than being involved in team events
are large social gatherings.
Very Dwight.
You like to think you are intelligent and well-educated with knowledge about many topics.
Yes.
You are good at anything that involves the mind rather than physical pursuits, chess, crosswords, card games, etc.
I don't know.
are large social gatherings. Very Dwight. Very Dwight. You like to think you are intelligent and well-educated with knowledge about many topics. Yes. You are good at anything that involves the mind rather than physical pursuits, chess, crosswords, card games, etc. I don't know. I don't know.
Where's paintball fall in there?
Also, he was pretty good at basketball.
Yeah.
All right.
Here are the final two.
You are a smart dresser and always dressed to impress.
Hmm.
Where's paintball fall in there? Also, he was pretty good at basketball. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Here are the final two. You are a smart dresser and always dressed to impress. Hmm.
Now, I think Dwight did like to dress nice.
I think in his mind, he took pride in his suit.
Yes, he did.
That's right.
Just because it maybe didn't land on others as fashionable,
it doesn't mean he wasn't making an effort to be polished each day.
in his way. Exactly. And then lastly, if you like the color yellow, you can also be arrogant,
pretentious, and snobbish. And if you want to get Dwight's look, you can go to tvstyleguide.com.
Now, I think Dwight did like to dress nice. I think in his mind, he took pride in his suit. Yes, he did. That's right. Just because it maybe didn't land on others as fashionable, it doesn't mean he wasn't making an effort to be polished each day. in his way. Exactly. And then lastly, if you like the color yellow, you can also be arrogant, pretentious, and snobbish. And if you want to get Dwight's look, you can go to tvstyleguide.com.
It's got the whole list of everything that makes up a Dwight look. That was delightful. It was
especially delightful coming from you dressed as you are. I wish everyone had a visual of this because it
really was great. Here, take a picture, and I'll put it in our stories. All right, I'm very excited to
hear all about Pam's cardigan. Well, it's interesting because initially, when we talked about this,
I was going to talk about the history of panty hose. You were. Because I wore so many pairs of
pantyhose as Pam. But when I started to deep dive it, it was kind of me. Like, it wasn't inspiring me.
Okay. So I pivoted, and I started to deep dive the cardigan sweater, something else that I wore a lot of.
on the office, and it did not disappoint. And lady, I think you in particular are going to love this.
It's got the whole list of everything that makes up a Dwight look. That was delightful. It was especially delightful coming from you dressed as you are. I wish everyone had a visual of this because it really was great. Here, take a picture, and I'll put it in our stories. All right, I'm very excited to hear all about Pam's cardigan. Well, it's interesting because initially, when we talked about this, I was going to talk about the history of panty hose. You were. Because I wore so many pairs of pantyhose as Pam. But when I started to deep dive it, it was kind of me. Like, it wasn't inspiring me. Okay. So I pivoted, and I started to deep dive the cardigan sweater, something else that I wore a lot of. on the office, and it did not disappoint. And lady, I think you in particular are going to love this.
Oh, my goodness. I'm so excited. You did bring a cardigan in today. I'm not wearing it because of my
hot flashes, but it's here. Yeah. It's on the back of my chair. So, according to the internet,
because I read several articles, the cardigan is named after James Thomas Brunnel, the seventh
Earl of Cardigan. So fussy. Yes. And it dates back to the mid-19th century because Thomas
Brudanel was a British Army officer who was famous for leading the charge of the Light Brigade
during the Crimean War. That could be a whole other podcast. Okay. This charge, it did not go well.
Oh, is this the office ladies do history? Yes. Basically,
he led a group of men on horses.
Oh, my goodness. I'm so excited. You did bring a cardigan in today. I'm not wearing it because of my hot flashes, but it's here. Yeah. It's on the back of my chair. So, according to the internet, because I read several articles, the cardigan is named after James Thomas Brunnel, the seventh Earl of Cardigan. So fussy. Yes. And it dates back to the mid-19th century because Thomas Brudanel was a British Army officer who was famous for leading the charge of the Light Brigade during the Crimean War. That could be a whole other podcast. Okay. This charge, it did not go well. Oh, is this the office ladies do history? Yes. Basically, he led a group of men on horses.
They had swords.
Okay.
And they charged the Russians who had artillery.
This is the cardigan guy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Swords versus artillery.
Artillery.
They had swords. Okay. And they charged the Russians who had artillery. This is the cardigan guy. Yeah. Okay. Swords versus artillery. Artillery.
Yes.
Basically, they had gotten some bad military intelligence.
Sounds like it.
But this whole battle, it made him famous and the men who were in the charge,
there were several fatalities and people.
taken as prisoners, but they were praised for their bravery in carrying out orders when they were so
outmatched. Like they didn't give up. They were like, this is what we were going to do, so we're going to
do it. Anyway, long story short, he became famous. And when he was in battle, he wore this kind of like
Yes. Basically, they had gotten some bad military intelligence. Sounds like it. But this whole battle, it made him famous and the men who were in the charge, there were several fatalities and people. taken as prisoners, but they were praised for their bravery in carrying out orders when they were so outmatched. Like they didn't give up. They were like, this is what we were going to do, so we're going to do it. Anyway, long story short, he became famous. And when he was in battle, he wore this kind of like
knitted wool jacket. And this jacket is considered the inspiration for the modern day cardigan.
And it looked like a vest with buttons in the front.
Okay.
And then later they added arms to it.
So it started as a vest.
As a knitted vest with buttons.
Then they added arms.
And it soon became sort of like a staple of the British Army's attire.
knitted wool jacket. And this jacket is considered the inspiration for the modern day cardigan. And it looked like a vest with buttons in the front. Okay. And then later they added arms to it. So it started as a vest. As a knitted vest with buttons. Then they added arms. And it soon became sort of like a staple of the British Army's attire.
And it was this garment.
It could keep them warm in battle, but it was also easily removed because they used to have like pull over sweaters and stuff.
Right.
But you don't have time for that.
You're in battle.
Yeah.
You know, you got to get that off quick if you're hot.
Right.
And it was this garment. It could keep them warm in battle, but it was also easily removed because they used to have like pull over sweaters and stuff. Right. But you don't have time for that. You're in battle. Yeah. You know, you got to get that off quick if you're hot. Right.
Also, unlike a traditional military jacket, it didn't restrict their movement.
It was like really easy to move their arms.
Dwight, by the way.
Yes, he would love this.
Because he needs circulation to his hands.
Yes, knitted military jacket, basically.
Transforms into the cardigan and was made famous by this guy.
So then by the late 1800s,
Also, unlike a traditional military jacket, it didn't restrict their movement. It was like really easy to move their arms. Dwight, by the way. Yes, he would love this. Because he needs circulation to his hands. Yes, knitted military jacket, basically. Transforms into the cardigan and was made famous by this guy. So then by the late 1800s,
it kind of transitioned into everyday fashion.
It was mostly worn by gentlemen while hunting or fishing.
So this really originated as a men's garment.
But then by the early 20th century, it made its way into women's fashion.
This was because knitting became a very popular hobby for women.
The cardigan was really an easy thing to knit and customize.
It was post-war.
People were trying to save money.
it kind of transitioned into everyday fashion. It was mostly worn by gentlemen while hunting or fishing. So this really originated as a men's garment. But then by the early 20th century, it made its way into women's fashion. This was because knitting became a very popular hobby for women. The cardigan was really an easy thing to knit and customize. It was post-war. People were trying to save money.
The sweater really moved.
into women's fashion as well.
And then Coco Chanel loved the cardigan,
and she is credited with bringing the cardigan
into the forefront of high fashion.
Do you see how the cardigan has moved
from the battlefield all the way to Coco Chanel?
Yeah.
The sweater really moved. into women's fashion as well. And then Coco Chanel loved the cardigan, and she is credited with bringing the cardigan into the forefront of high fashion. Do you see how the cardigan has moved from the battlefield all the way to Coco Chanel? Yeah.
Come on.
Then in the 1950s,
the cardigan gained popularity in the United States
because people like Grace Kelly and Marilyn Monroe
were frequently photographed wearing a cardigan.
For women, cardigans were considered stylish
and preppy.
for men, they were still going strong, but they were sort of like, if you were an intellectual or an
Come on. Then in the 1950s, the cardigan gained popularity in the United States because people like Grace Kelly and Marilyn Monroe were frequently photographed wearing a cardigan. For women, cardigans were considered stylish and preppy. for men, they were still going strong, but they were sort of like, if you were an intellectual or an
academic, like Albert Einstein wore a lot of cardigans. So if you were a smarty pants, you might be in a
carigan now. Right. And then, of course, in the 1980s, with grunge fashion, you had Kurt Cobain
rocking the slouchy cardigans. So the cardigan is kind of just an amazing item of clothing. It is
evolved over time. It has taken so many forms. But in all of its forms, it is
functional, practical, it can be styled up or down, and it's a really great way to add warmth
to an outfit or to remove if you get too hot. And that brings me to Pam, who wears her cardigan
to face a sort of different kind of artillery, the word vomit that is Michael Scott. I feel like
that's a special... Bam, bam! I feel like that's a special battle that she went to every day
学术界人士，比如阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦就穿过很多开衫。所以如果你是个书呆子，你现在可能也穿着一件开衫。没错。然后，当然，在20世纪80年代的垃圾摇滚时尚中，库尔特·柯本穿着宽松的开衫。所以开衫真是一件了不起的服装。它随着时间不断演变。它拥有无数种形态。但在所有的形态中，它都是功能性的、实用的，无论是盛装还是便装都能驾驭，而且它真的是一种为服装增添温暖或在觉得太热时脱掉的绝佳方式。这就让我想到了帕姆，她穿着开衫来面对一种不同类型的炮火，那就是迈克尔·斯科特式的胡言乱语。我觉得那是一种特殊的……砰，砰！我觉得那是她每天都要经历的一场特殊战斗
in her cardigan. Yep. I wore so many cardigans on the office. I have. I wore so many cardigans on the office. I
I still regret that I didn't like capitalize on that and put out a line of cardigans.
You still can.
I know.
Never say never.
I could totally see Pam's sweaters brought to you by Jenna Fisher at some department store.
I know.
How do people do that?
穿着她的开衫。没错。我在《办公室》里穿了超级多开衫。我有。我在《办公室》里穿了太多开衫了。我……我至今仍然后悔当时没有好好利用这一点，推出一个开衫系列。你现在还可以。我知道。世事无绝对。我完全可以想象在某家百货公司里由珍娜·费舍尔为你带来的帕姆毛衣。我知道。人们是怎么做到的呢？
How do you get a perfume?
I don't know.
How do you get a wine?
How do you get a cardigan?
Like, I don't understand.
I don't know.
Lady, remember when we very first started the podcast, I'm,
你怎么能搞到一个香水品牌？我不知道。你怎么能搞到一个葡萄酒品牌？我不知道。你怎么能搞到一个开衫系列？就像，我完全不理解。我不知道。天哪，还记得我们刚开始做播客的时候吗，我是说，
talking 2019. You're going to bring up the rosé. I said I wanted an office lady's rosé.
You about killed me with that. I started doing research. Lady, I talked to a winery about it.
I know. And it just was like, it was so hard. It's like another job. It's like another job.
Yes. We're like, we already have a job. The bandwidth for all these like variations of themselves. I don't know.
I don't know. But I love that you immediately were like, you're going to talk about the rosé.
I mean, that was like a year of my life.
Anyway, I mean, Brian Cretton, they have their whole mescal.
Mescal.
说到2019年。你又要提起桃红葡萄酒了。我说过我想要一款“办公室女郎”桃红葡萄酒。你当时差点把我气死。我开始做调研。天哪，我甚至跟一家酒庄谈过这事。我知道。然后就觉得，这太难了。这就好像是另一份工作。这就像是另一份工作。是的。我们当时就想，我们本来就有一份工作了。要应付所有这些副业所需的精力。我不知道。我不知道。但我喜欢你一听到这就立刻说，你肯定又要聊桃红葡萄酒了。我是说，那几乎花了我一年的时间。不管怎样，我是说，布莱恩和克雷顿，他们有自己的梅斯卡尔酒。梅斯卡尔酒。
I know.
Where's the office ladies rosé?
Where is it?
Where's Pam's cardigans?
I don't know.
Jenna Fisher's cardigans.
我知道。“办公室女郎”桃红葡萄酒在哪里？它在哪里？帕姆的开衫在哪里？我不知道。珍娜·费舍尔的开衫在哪里？我不知道。我不知道。
Angela Martin's catbeds.
Where are these things?
Who does this?
How do you do the side hustle?
Someone write us.
So anyway, I wore a lot of cardigans on the office.
And we've discussed before how the costume department made each of us a closet of clothes.
Yeah.
安吉拉·马丁的猫窝在哪里？这些东西都在哪儿？谁在做这些？你是怎么搞副业的？大家给我们写信吧。总之，我在《办公室》里穿了很多开衫。我们之前讨论过服装部门是如何为我们每个人准备一间衣橱的。是的。
And mine had pencil skirts, button down shirts, and cardigans.
And they would just mix and match them for various episodes.
And it was really important to the reality of our characters that we repeat clothing.
So you see things repeat.
And it's funny because I found a ton of articles of people.
breaking down Pam's cardigans according to their colors and how they relate to the episodes.
And I just want everyone to know that was intentional. You are right on. My color palette was
mostly pastels like shades of pink or mint green or light blue. But I did also wear some more muted
而我的衣橱里有铅笔裙、衬衫和开衫。他们会把这些衣服混搭用于不同的剧集。对于我们角色的真实性来说，重复穿衣服非常重要。所以你会看到衣服重复出现。这很有趣，因为我找到了大量文章，人们根据帕姆开衫的颜色以及它们与剧情的联系来对其进行剖析。我只想让大家知道，那是刻意为之的。你们猜得很对。我的色调主要是粉色、薄荷绿或浅蓝色等粉彩色系。但我也穿了一些更低调的
colors. There are some grays. There are some beige's. And there was purpose to what colors were
chosen each week. Like, for example, I'm wearing a beige cardigan in the episode The Secret,
and that is the episode where Jim tells Pam that he 100% does not have a crush on her anymore.
And so we wanted me to be, like, muted, you know, because my heart is being muted.
Yeah. And then also there were times when things were scripted, like in the merger, Pam says,
oh, my mom knitted this for me. Mm-hmm. There's a lot.
a chatter online about whether or not that was truly a hand-knit cardigan, I want everyone to know when
we broke down that episode, I revealed that it was not. It was store-bought, but there were modifications
颜色。有一些灰色。有一些米色。每周选择什么颜色都是有目的的。比如，我在《秘密》那一集中穿着一件米色开衫，那一集讲的是吉姆告诉帕姆他百分之百不再对她有好感了。所以我们希望我看起来比较低调，你知道的，因为我的心正在变得黯淡。是的。另外，有时有些剧情是写在剧本里的，比如在合并那一集里，帕姆说，哦，我妈妈给我织了这个。嗯哼。网上有很多讨论，关于那到底是不是一件手工织的开衫，我想让大家知道，当我们剖析那一集时，我透露过它其实不是。那是买来的，但做了一些
made. We added that big chunky button. We tried to add things to make it look hand-knit. But I mean,
it's like we got that script one week. Who's like fascinating this sweater for me? I guess they could
have found a hand-knit sweater, but we're going for something specific. Also, though, in a time crunch,
it's just harder to find those very specific handmade things.
And you need duplicates of everything.
Every outfit we had two of in case you got coffee spilled on it or who knows what.
I don't know, but every outfit had a duplicate outfit.
So to find two identical hand-knit sweaters in five days, that was a challenge.
修改。我们加上了那个大号粗呢纽扣。我们试图添加一些元素来让它看起来像是手工织的。但我的意思是，就好像我们那一周才拿到剧本。谁能马上为我织好这件毛衣？我想他们本可以找到一件手工织的毛衣，但我们要追求的是某种特定的效果。不过话说回来，在时间紧迫的情况下，要找到那些非常独特的手工制品更加困难。而且每件衣服你都需要复制品。我们的每套服装都有两套，以防咖啡泼洒在上面或者发生别的什么情况。我不知道，但每套服装都有一个副本。所以要在五天内找到两件一模一样的手工毛衣，那可真是个挑战。
Yeah, exactly.
The color I wore the least that I only wore for holiday episodes was red.
and my favorite cardigan is that vintage holiday cardigan that I wear.
It's so great.
I'm still bummed.
I don't have it.
We have scoured the internet to see if there's another one out there.
They don't make it anymore.
对，没错。我穿得最少、只在节日剧集里穿的颜色是红色。而我最喜欢的开衫是我在节日特辑中穿的那件复古开衫。太棒了。我到现在还很遗憾我没有留着它。我们曾在网上到处搜寻，看看是否还能找到另一件。他们已经不再生产了。
Yes.
But everyone, if you pay attention to Pam's arc, whatever she's going through emotionally,
and you note her cardigan, there is often a correlation, and that was intentional.
And one final thing, Angela, you know, and we've shared.
before, that they always tried to buy our clothing at stores that reflected the price point of what
our characters could actually afford from whatever our salary might be at Dunder Mifflin.
This was true of all of my sweaters, but there's one very big exception. It's my finale cardigan.
That's the gray cardigan with the sequins that I wear in that final talking head.
是的。但是各位，如果你注意帕姆的心路历程，无论她当时经历了怎样的情绪起伏，并注意她的开衫，你会发现它们之间往往存在某种关联，而那是刻意安排的。还有最后一件事，安吉拉，你知道的，我们也分享过，他们总是尽量在一些商店里为我们买衣服，这些商店的价位要符合我们的角色在邓德米夫林所领的薪水能够负担得起的水平。我所有的毛衣都是如此，但有一个非常大的例外。那就是我在大结局里穿的开衫。那是那件带有亮片的灰色开衫，我在最后接受单人采访时穿的。
That was by Diane von Furstenberg. It costs around $300. But we wanted Pam to literally shine.
That was her last cardigan.
You literally sparkle.
Yes.
Like the light hits all those little like stones and you shimmer.
And I did keep that one.
I have a blue one, a pink one, and I have the sparkly one.
那是黛安·冯芙丝汀宝（Diane von Furstenberg）的作品。售价大约在300美元左右。但我们希望帕姆能够真正地闪耀光芒。那是她的最后一件开衫。你真的在发光。是的。就像光线照在所有那些小小的宝石上，你整个人都在闪闪发光。是的。我确实把那件留作纪念了。我有一件蓝色的，一件粉色的，还有那件亮片的。
Oh, that's great.
Yes.
So that's your little history on the cardigan and a little bit more info on Pam's cardigans, everybody.
Well, I loved every second of that.
And I loved how much thought went into our show and how many layers there were to just any
episode you watch. Well, it's true. I mean, something as simple as, you know, a work shirt or a
cardigan, they were items of clothing, but they were used to tell a story. 100%. I mean, Angela Martin
definitely had her different outfits for different occasions, even though they were all shades of gray.
哦，太棒了。是的。所以这就是关于开衫的一点历史，以及关于帕姆开衫的更多信息，各位。好吧，我喜欢其中的每一秒钟。我喜欢我们的节目投入了多少心血，而且无论你看哪一集，里面都包含着如此多的层次。确实如此。我的意思是，像工作衬衫或开衫这样简单的事情，它们虽然是衣服，但它们被用来讲述一个故事。百分之百。我是说，安吉拉·马丁在不同的场合绝对有不同的服装，尽管它们全都是各种深浅的灰色。
And cream. All right, well, why don't we take a break? We'll be back with some Around the Town and our office
question of the week. We are back, and our first Around the Town comes from Sally S in Evansville, Indiana,
who said, this weekend, our local Girls on the Run Council held the celebratory 5K events for the girls in our program.
I was honored to serve as the head for our planning committee and I'm so proud of our team for putting on the largest and most successful event in our county.
Shout out to all of the go-ter councils across the U.S. who offer this amazing program and put on the celebratory 5Ks.
You are making a difference in so many young girls' lives.
Sally, this is great. I've shared before, my sister is a Girls on the Run volunteer. She helps plan
and participate in the 5K event each year in St. Louis. She loves being a part of this program.
和米色。好了，我们为什么不休息一下呢？稍后回来带来“走过小镇”环节和我们的本周办公室问答。我们回来了，我们的第一个“走过小镇”环节来自印第安纳州埃文斯维尔的莎莉·S，她说：“这个周末，我们当地的‘女孩在奔跑’委员会为我们项目中的女孩们举办了庆祝性的5公里长跑活动。我很荣幸能担任我们规划委员会的负责人，我为我们的团队感到无比自豪，因为我们成功举办了我们县规模最大、最成功的活动。”向全美所有提供这个精彩项目并举办庆祝性5公里长跑的“女孩在奔跑”委员会致敬。你们正在改变无数年轻女孩的生活。莎莉，这太棒了。我之前分享过，我姐姐就是一名“女孩在奔跑”的志愿者。她每年都在圣路易斯协助策划和参与5公里长跑活动。她非常热爱这个项目。
What a great organization. Sally, thanks for writing in. And our next one is from William S in Orange
County, California. William says, in what might be the most wholesome community event ever,
Orange County Speed Puzzlers hosted an all-day puzzle hangout for members of the local jigsaw puzzling community.
Puzzlers of all skill levels met in Mission Viejo to enjoy each other's company over their shared love of jigsaw puzzles.
From group puzzling to individual speed puzzling to a 500-piece team speed puzzling challenge to puzzle piece stacking and more.
This unique event was essentially a day of summer camp activities for adults.
I want to go.
I love to puzzle.
多么棒的一个组织啊。莎莉，谢谢你的来信。我们的下一条信息来自加利福尼亚州橙县的威廉·S。威廉说：“在堪称史上最健康的社区活动中，橙县极速拼图爱好者为当地的拼图爱好者社区举办了一整天的拼图聚会。各种水平的拼图爱好者齐聚米申维约，通过他们对拼图的共同热爱来享受彼此的陪伴。从集体拼图到个人极速拼图，再到500片团队极速拼图挑战，以及拼图块堆叠等等。这个独特的活动本质上就是成年人的夏令营活动日。”我想去。我太喜欢拼图了。
I love puzzling.
You know, that time of year where it's just like rainy and whatever and you don't go out as much.
And I'm like, ooh, let's bust out a puzzle.
Yeah.
I love Ravensburger.
Yes, they're the best.
That's the best puzzle.
我喜欢拼图。我喜欢拼图。你知道，一年中的那个时候，外面下着雨什么的，你不会经常出门。然后我就想，哦，让我们来拼个拼图吧。是的。我喜欢雷欢堡（Ravensburger）。是的，它们是最棒的。那是最好的拼图。
Yes.
Agree.
They have a new series right now called the Cozy Series.
It's all exactly what it sounds like.
A cozy ski cabin.
A cozy beach cabin.
A cozy reading.
nook and you puzzle this little cozy world. There's always a cup of warm liquid and there's like a
是的，同感。他们现在有一个新系列叫做“温馨系列”。一切正如其名。一个温馨的滑雪小屋。一个温馨的海滩小屋。一个温馨的阅读角落，你就在拼图里拼出这个小小的温馨世界。里面总有一杯温热的液体，还有像是一
little puppy or something sitting on a rug or in a basket. Lady, for your Yankeeswap Christmas party
this past year, if you remember, I know you love that I brought the disco ball in the champagne.
Very much. But we had to bring five gifts because it was my whole family and one of our gifts was
a big box with three Ravensburger puzzles in it. It was a hot item. I know. It got
stolen. Multiple times. Not stolen for real, but like in the game. Of course. They're really the best.
Talk about a dainty delight. The feeling of a Ravensburger puzzle piece.
If you need something to bring to a Yankee swap, let me tell you that was heavily traded.
Can I also tell you that I was at a party and someone shared with me that instead of a book club,
小狗什么的坐在小地毯上或篮子里。女士们，为了你们去年的扬基交换圣延派对，如果你们还记得的话，我知道你们很喜欢我带去的香槟和迪斯科球。非常喜欢。但我们必须带五件礼物，因为那是我的整个家族，我们的礼物之一是一个装着三个雷鸟拼图的大盒子。这是个热门货。我知道。它被偷了。好多次。不是真的被偷，而是在游戏里。当然。它们真的是最好的。简直是个精致的快乐。雷鸟拼图那种拼图块的手感。如果你需要带什么去参加扬基交换，我得告诉你，那个被疯狂交易。我还能告诉你们，我曾在一次派对上，有人跟我分享说，比起读书俱乐部，
they have a puzzle club, and once a month, they get together, they order takeout and they drink wine
and they just puzzle until the puzzle's done.
That sounds like an amazing evening.
I know.
And you don't have to do anything ahead of time.
You don't.
I have friends back in my hometown in Texas that get together and they do embroidery,
and they call it Stitch and Bitch.
他们有一个拼图俱乐部，一个月一次，他们聚在一起，点外卖，喝红酒，然后就一直拼拼图，直到拼图拼完。听起来像是一个美妙的夜晚。我懂。而且你不需要提前做任何事。确实不用。我在德克萨斯州家乡的朋友们聚在一起做刺绣，他们把这叫作“边绣边吐槽”。
All right.
Our last around the town is coming from Grace H.
In Connecticut, who said, ladies, I have listened to the podcast since the very beginning
when I would put it on as I drove to high school.
I am now graduating college.
I am completing my bachelor's of architecture at Syracuse University.
Woo-hoo!
Yes.
好了。我们最后一个“走过小镇”环节来自康涅狄格州的格蕾丝·H，她说，女士们，我从这个播客刚开播时就开始听了，那时我开车去高中时会放它听。我现在大学毕业了。我在锡拉丘兹大学完成了建筑学学士学位。呜呼！太棒了。
And your podcast has been by my side from late nights, making models to walking around campus
and everywhere in between.
I'm so excited for what's next for me and can't wait to be listening to the podcast wherever
I end up.
Well, congratulations, Grace.
And to everyone graduating this spring, we get a lot of graduation announcements in our snail mail as
well. Yep. And we thought we could shout a few of those out. Yeah, let's do it. Jessica G.
from Fort Wayne graduated from Indiana University of Diagnostic Medical Sonography.
而且你们的播客一直陪伴在我身边，从深夜做模型到在校园里漫步以及之间的每一个地方。我为自己的下一步感到非常兴奋，也迫不及待地想在无论我最终身在何处的任何地方收听这个播客。好吧，恭喜你，格蕾丝。也祝贺今年春天毕业的所有人，我们在实体信件中也收到了很多毕业通知。是的。我们觉得我们可以顺便喊出其中的一些人。是的，我们来吧。韦恩堡的杰西卡·G毕业于印第安纳大学诊断医学超声技术专业。
Gianna A from Leesburg, Florida graduated high school with plans to attend Southeastern University
and major in ministerial leadership. Justina from New Jersey is graduating college with a graphic
design and fine arts major and she is currently working in Philly. It's kind of like Justina
is living Pam's life if Pam had gotten her degree.
And finally, congrats to Carly S from Enterprise, Alabama, Sarah G from J. from Joliet Junior
College, Katie M from San Antonio, Texas, and Hannah B from Arkansas. We got your announcements,
and we are wishing you all the best. We really love getting these announcements each spring,
so please keep them coming. Our PO box is on our website. We did want to say one thing,
来自佛罗里达州利斯堡的吉安娜·A高中毕业，计划就读东南大学并主修牧养领导力。新泽西州的朱斯蒂娜大学毕业，主修平面设计和美术，她目前在费城工作。这就有点像朱斯蒂娜在过着帕姆的生活，如果帕姆获得了学位的话。最后，祝贺来自阿拉巴马州恩特普赖斯的卡莉·S、来自乔利埃特初级学院的莎拉·G·J、来自得克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的凯蒂·M以及来自阿肯色州的汉娜·B。我们收到了你们的通知，祝你们一切顺利。我们真的很喜欢每年春天收到这些通知，所以请继续发给我们。我们的邮政信箱在我们的网站上。我们确实有一件事要说，
though. We are very sorry, but we cannot accommodate autograph requests. So,
please do not send us your funcop pop box because they get sorted out. Yeah. And we don't want you to not have
that. But we love hearing from you guys. Please, when you write us your letters, when you send us your
graduation announcements, your wedding invitations, all of those are so wonderful. We'll share things like
that and around the town. All right. I think it's time for us to move on to our office question the week.
But dare I say, reading people's around the towns is another dainty delight. It is.
Thank you. Way to bring it full circle.
All right. This is from Louise F from Scotland, who said, hey, office ladies, I have always wondered,
不过。非常抱歉，我们无法满足签名请求。所以，请不要给我们寄你们的芬可波普盒子，因为它们会被挑拣出来。是的。而且我们不希望你们没有那个东西。但我们喜欢听你们分享。拜托，当你们给我们写信，当你们给我们寄毕业通知、婚礼请柬时，所有这些都太棒了。我们会分享类似这样的事情以及走过小镇环节。好了。我想是时候进入我们本周的办公室问题了。但我敢说，阅读大家的走过小镇环节是另一个精致的快乐。确实是。谢谢。真会首尾呼应。好了。这是来自苏格兰的路易斯·F，她说，嘿，办公室女士们，我一直很好奇，
what would happen if someone was the main focus of an episode one week, but when it came to filming,
they were so ill that they couldn't come to set. Would the episode be rewritten or filmed a different
week? Surely, with the amount of episodes you guys filmed, this was bound to happen at some point.
Oh, Louise. Oh, Louise. Louise, first of all, hi from Scotland. I love Scotland.
Yes. Okay, I just had to say that. Okay. Because I went there for my honeymoon. You know how much I love Scotland.
Okay. Now I'm going to focus. Yes. So here's the thing. We had to just go to work anyway,
basically is the short answer. There are so many moving parts and so many people involved in pulling an episode together that if it was written and planned and there was a shoot schedule, it was very hard to undo that.
And yes, every once in a while it happened.
如果有人某周成为一集的核心焦点，但当到了拍摄时，他们病得那么重以至于无法来到片场，会发生什么呢？这一集会被重写还是在不同的一周拍摄？当然，考虑到你们拍摄的剧集数量，这迟早是会发生的。哦，路易斯。哦，路易斯。路易斯，首先，来自苏格兰的问候。我爱苏格兰。是的。好吧，我不得不这么说。好吧。因为我去那里度蜜月。你知道我多爱苏格兰。好吧。现在我要集中注意力了。是的。所以情况是这样的。基本上简短的回答是，我们无论如何都得去工作。有太多的动态因素和那么多的人参与来把一集节目拼凑在一起，如果它已经写好并计划好了，而且有一个拍摄日程，要取消它是非常困难的。是的，偶尔确实会发生这种情况。
Like if someone was truly too sick to come to set, we might rearrange some of the week's schedule to give them an afternoon off or a morning off or maybe the whole day off.
But it was very difficult and very rare.
It was very rare.
They would try to, like Jenna said, move the schedule so maybe you could go home early, you know, pull up someone else's talking heads, things like that.
but mostly we just muscled through it.
The only time I remember us doing a big switcheroo was Dwight's speech because Rain was so,
so sick.
And he was the focus of that episode.
就像如果有人真的病得太重而无法来到片场，我们可能会重新安排这周的一些日程，给他们半天假或一个早上假，或者可能是整整一天假。但这非常困难，而且非常罕见。非常罕见。他们会尽量，就像珍娜说的，调整日程，也许你可以早点回家，你知道，把别人的访谈镜头提上来，诸如此类。但大多数情况下，我们只是咬牙坚持过去。我唯一记得我们做过重大调整的一次是德懷特的演讲，因为雷恩病得太厉害了。而且他是那一集的焦点。
We had to film at that hotel.
And that was one time I remember I got a call from our AD and they were like, okay,
the hotel has been canceled.
We're moving things around.
Rain's going to the doctor.
He's too sick.
Yeah.
But really, I mean, you could probably count on one hand.
我们不得不去那个酒店拍摄。那是少数我记得我接到副导演电话的一次，他们说，好吧，酒店取消了。我们在调整事情。雷恩要去医生那里。他病得太厉害了。是的。但说真的，我的意思是，你大概可以一只手就数过来。
the number of times that happened.
Yeah, there were sometimes like life events, like a death in the family.
Mm-hmm.
And I remember we made space for people, obviously, to go grieve and be with their families.
But if someone was sick, you had to kind of just power through.
I mean, I had false labor and went to work the next day.
I was in the hospital and they called, remember, Ken's Born?
I was like, Angela, are we having this baby?
这种事情发生的次数。是的，有时会有生活事件，比如家里有人去世。嗯嗯。我记得我们显然腾出空间让大家去悲伤并与家人在一起。但如果有人生病了，你基本上只能咬牙坚持。我的意思是，我假临产，第二天还去上班。我在医院，他们打电话来，还记得肯斯·伯恩吗？我当时想，安吉拉，我们要把这个孩子生下来吗？
tonight because it was the next day where Andy proposes and the Ferris will and all that. And I was like,
I'll let you know. I totally remember that. And listen, this is not exclusive to the office.
No, no, no. This is the entertainment industry. When I did the movie Walk Hard, John C. Riley got really
sick. I think he had like a strep throat or something. And we had to do like a whole makeout scene
anyway. And then I got sick and I got so sick that I lost my voice. I had laryngitis. I couldn't
speak. And I was really sick. And they were like, you still have to come to work. I'm like, how?
How? I can't speak. They're like, we're going to shoot some stuff where you're not talking today.
I mean, it's like you're going to just show up. It is pretty bonkers. It is. And we're kind of laughing because I think in hindsight,
今晚，因为第二天安迪要求婚，还有摩天轮什么的。然后我说，我会让你知道的。我完全记得那个。听着，这并不是《办公室》所独有的。不，不，不。这是娱乐产业。当我拍电影《永不止步》时，约翰·C·赖利病得很重。我想他得了链球菌性咽喉炎什么的。不管怎样，我们还是得拍一整场亲热戏。然后我也病了，我病得连声音都说不出来了。我得了喉炎。我不会说话了。而且我病得很重。他们说，你还是得去上班。我说，怎么去？怎么去？我不会说话。他们说，我们今天要拍一些你不用说话的内容。我的意思是，就像你还是得出现。这太疯狂了。确实。我们有点在笑，因为我想事后来看，
sometimes you look back at those moments, you're like, what?
But it does involve so many moving parts and so many people that they are just constantly
trying to make sure they make their day and get something shot because they have a limited time
and a limited budget.
Yes.
And there is like this element of the show must go on.
And that's been a part of, you know, actors.
Yes.
有时你回想起那些时刻，你会想，什么？但这确实涉及太多的活动部件和那么多的人，以至于他们一直在努力确保他们完成当日拍摄任务并拍到一些镜头，因为他们有有限的时间和有限的预算。是的。而且有一种“演出必须继续”的元素。这也是演员的一部分，你知道的。是的。
For all time, the show must go on.
And there is that spirit when you're making a movie or you're making a TV show.
And I think I've famously told the story of how incredibly sick I was one week at the office.
And I took a bunch of Sudafed.
Yes.
So I could make it through.
And didn't Greg say it was one of your best performances?
Greg.
一直以来，演出必须继续。当你拍电影或拍电视剧时，确实有那种精神。我想我曾有名地讲述过我在办公室的一个星期里病得有多厉害的故事。我吃了一堆伪麻黄碱。是的。所以我才能熬过去。格里格不是说那是你最好的表演之一吗？格里格。
He like reached out to your agent or something.
I called my manager and was like, Jenna was incredible today.
Incredible.
You're like, I was super suitorfed it up.
Exactly.
I'm like, oh, I don't know what that says.
But anyway, thank you for that question.
Yeah, we just.
他甚至联系了你的经纪人什么的。我打电话给我的经纪人说，珍娜今天太不可思议了。太不可思议了。你就像是，我吃了超级多的伪麻黄碱。没错。我说，哦，我不知道这说明了什么。但无论如何，谢谢你提出那个问题。 yeah, 我们只是。
We just powered through.
We did.
Well, everyone, this was such a fun episode.
Thank you so much for listening.
I want to give a special thank you to Holiday Reinhorn for sharing her story about the origin of Dwight's button down shirt.
Amazing.
And of course, you guys, I'll put links in our stories where you can check out the amazing organization that Rain and Holly have put so much of their heart and time into Lide, Haiti.
And thank you to, oh, my goodness, the amazing.
我们只是咬牙坚持。我们确实做到了。好了，各位，这真是一集有趣的节目。非常感谢你们的收听。我要特别感谢霍莉·雷恩霍恩分享关于德怀特纽扣衬衫起源的故事。太棒了。当然，各位，我会把链接放在我们的故事里，你们可以在那里查看雷恩和霍莉倾注了大量心血和时间的伟大组织——海地利德。还要感谢，哦，天哪，了不起的。
Christy D from Wheeling, West Virginia, who sent in the Diaries of the Mustard shirt.
What a delight. Talk about a dainty delight was reading that.
Thank you for inspiring this episode, Christy.
We'll see you guys all next week.
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
来自西弗吉尼亚州惠灵的克里斯蒂·D，她寄来了《芥末衬衫日记》。真是个惊喜。阅读那封信简直是一种精致的快乐。谢谢你激发了这一集，克里斯蒂。我们下周再见。到时候见。感谢收听办公室女士们。《办公室女士们》是奥德赛的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
奥德赛的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士们的混音和母带制作由比尔·舒尔茨完成。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特里》。